if we get Star Trek Legacy we're going
to get an upgraded Enterprise
or are we welcome to psychecky Sci-Fi TV
and movie time
[Music]
one of my biggest complaints about
Picard season 3 a series I adored a
series actually got up early for each
day to watch
was that I hated that they changed the
Titan and they read christeneda into the
new Enterprise G
names mean almost everything
I absolutely hate that they did that for
a couple of reasons
for one generally speaking when you get
a new ship it's better than the one that
came before it it's an upgrade it's a
new ship the Titan is not better I would
say it's maybe on par with the D I don't
think it's as good as the E it's
definitely not as good as the F you know
the Odyssey class was a far superior
vessel to this new Titan the new
Enterprise G
so
there's that also the Enterprise G got
its ass handed to it
repeatedly now it has been in space dock
for a year so it could have already been
upgraded
but this was a vessel that took one look
at the strike and cacked its pants
Captain Shaw didn't even want to engage
it God damn it
tactical full power to forward Shields
the forwards Get Ready To Fly he just he
got one look at it and went new so the
Enterprise G is not exactly
awe-inspiring now that's not necessarily
a major problem to be honest Federation
Starships have always kind of been
second best you know in a fight in lots
and lots of episodes of Star Trek but it
would be nice not to be so far behind
everything else but maybe there's a
light at the end of the tunnel because
Screen Rants have released a story today
saying the Enterprise G will get an
upgrade the David Blaster production
designer has confirmed if we get Star
Trek Legacy 100 I would love to upgrade
that ship
so new weapons new shields new armor
reactive arm whatever all new technology
would be awesome no unfortunately I
don't think that's exactly what he meant
so to be clear
screen Lance title Star Trek legacy's
new Enterprise will be upgraded says
production designer
you then actually read what he says oh
yeah 100 I'd love to yay new Enterprise
because we did season two and three back
to back there wasn't any time to change
really the bridge from the Stargazer to
the Titan but if we get into going to
series with Legacy oh yeah we'll
definitely tweak that one he's not
talking about upgrading the Enterprise
he's talking about upgrading this set of
the Enterprise G because it's basically
the same as the set for the Stargazer
from season two they didn't really
change anything so basically the set was
the same because they filmed Picard
season two and three back to back so if
they get Legacy he's basically saying
that they will have plenty of time to
upgrade the set to make it an actual
more interesting and actually bespoke
set for that series it will be that
Titan not a slightly painted over
version of the Stargazer so that is to
say the least a little disappointing I
actually really think that if we do get
Star Trek Legacy and I've spoken to you
guys a couple times before now that I
honestly believe we are and sources that
I speak to are Paramount basically
telling me they would love to it really
is just a money thing and you know
scheduling thing then I actually think
we need an upgraded Enterprise the
Enterprise that we've got currently is
not the vessel we want to see exploring
the stars and we don't want to see it
having to run away from every enemy it
comes across because it is so massively
underpowered but
as I said earlier this vessel was in
space dock for nearly a year we saw that
at the end of Picard season three
so it would be very easy to write in the
fact that it's already had a massive
upgrade and if the set is completely
different in the bridge it's kind of
different we'll just ignore that if it
means we actually get an Enterprise a
Starship that is deserved of the name it
is supposed to be the flagship of the
Federation it is supposed to be one of
starfleet's most famous vessels
and really the Enterprise G in its
current form for me at least
doesn't stand up to that title
so I was disappointed they did it in the
first place
I'm kind of disappointed by screenwright
story because I think the headline is
massively clickbaiting and to be honest
my headline for this video is going to
be a bit clickbaity but for a reason
I hope though that the writers fill in a
few of those blanks and realize their
mistakes
because we want an Enterprise that
really goes out and explores strange new
worlds and seeks out new life and new
civilizations but doesn't get its ass
handed to them by all of those
civilizations that'd be nice
but guys what do you think was turning
the Titan a into the Enterprise G a
mistake do you agree with me that
actually this is a massively
underpowered vessel compared to other
ships in the fleet The Odyssey is nearly
twice its size for one or actually do
you like that if the Plucky and the dog
you know getting out there exploring and
you know it's not overly powered it will
have to be clever rather than dealing
with problems with Brute Force
it could make for more interesting TV
show and lots of ways what do you think
get into the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution each
month that really supports the channel
you get a free gift after three months
and you get to see those videos without
the adverts on YouTube
bonus you can also go to
sidetrack.co.uk which is our dedicated
website where we do articles based on
most of our videos and we try to add a
little bit more information in there for
you to digest please go and check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]